hi mike big fan thanks i've watched a
lot of your content
and uh i have one question has a little
bit of a context i wasn't at the front
of the line
but uh i actually disagree with your
little thesis here my primary question
is that you misconstrue a lot of data on
your show
and tell a lot of outright lies and you
did a lot so here but
you know you talk a lot about
rationality and a good discussion a lot
of
you know reasonable stuff but it was
curious when you were talking
i didn't hear any science i didn't hear
any rational discussion and if you want
to have rational discussion say about
i don't know climate change or
transgenderism i actually have studies
here i mean that would take too much
time
but i don't know how much you'd be well
what give an example of a lie that i
said
uh the 6 000 kids you said that were
given hormone blockers because of some
trans conception i corrected that the
next day when the news was corrected
yeah well
corrected but it was in the study you
said it was a trans activist
or some trans conspiracy i said it was a
drug that was used for transgender kids
which is true
and i said that it caused 6 000 debts
which is true but what i misspoke and
what was misreported in the news
is that all six thousand were kids and
that obviously was not true and i
corrected it on my show the next day
it goes further than that because it had
nothing to do with transgenderism it was
about terminally ill patients
but it was blocker for hormonally
sensitive cancers
right they were dying from cancer and
they were trying to i know that that's
why it was misreported and that's why i
corrected them that's reported no you
did the misreporting
no i mean i was one of many people who
you can't misreported the rationality
here it's your responsibility
i think it's very rational to correct
yourself when you make a mistake and
that's why i do it
every time i every time i can
but i think it's your responsibility as
a political commentator to a lot of
impressionable
young people here that you report
accurately and that's not i agree and
that's why
when i do make a mistake rare though it
may be i correct myself
is there is there an example you said i
told a lot of lies tonight what would be
an example of guys tonight well
no you didn't say last night you lack
rationality you didn't cite any evidence
to to talk about the climate change i
said that the the
mankind is not going to be wiped out
within 20 years because no scientists
say
i'm sorry science would disagree uh
which scientist
the uh the 97 percent of all scientists
who say that one to two degrees
celsius will mount the ice caps
such that there will be rising sea
levels mass extinctions
and it won't end the earth but it will
change
to a certain point the ecology of our
planet such that it is much
more difficult for humans to survive
that is the consensus
and a lot of climate change deniers like
yourself like ben like clavin
they they they perpetuate that this is
all a liberal hoax and that in that
science
i'm not saying it's a liberal i mean
it's obviously being pushed by
politicians primarily that's why at the
united
nations it's not politics politicians
are going to push political issues right
it's politics not science that's my
point
no you take the science and then you say
i don't which study
what you're citing that 97 number has
been around for a long time
al gore used it in his movie one issue
with that is
first of all science is not made by
consensus but second of all the
questions that were asked were such
broad questions as to a whole array of
scientists
many of whom had no expertise in the
climate whatsoever so the the to use a
a consensus number especially one that's
so old and was
has been so manipulated by politicians
is i think not really
getting to the point we don't we don't
take polls to figure out
scientific data so if you think the
world is going to end in 20 years
as polit oh i thought you said that you
thought so it's going to change to a
certain point such a human habitation
will be more difficult and it will be
vastly different
i'm not a doomsday you know idiot and
it's not an old figure it's ongoing it's
right now
you know no it's a figure is decades old
right now the 97
figure is decades old well sure but it's
still accurate
okay i'm out of time real pleasure it
was a pleasure
i'm glad you could come up and ask those
questions